N
OPERATING UNDER FEDERAL CHARTER.
BACK TO YOU.
>> Carley: CONGRESSWELCOME
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ HAS AN
INTERESTING TAKE ON MOU MEDICARE
AND SOCIAL SECURITY WORK, LISTEN
TO THIS.
>> QUITE A FEW COUNTRIES ARE
STRUGGLING UNDER BURDEN OF UPON
CAPITALISM AMONG THE RICH, WE'RE
NOT HAVING KIDS OR NOT HAVING
KIDS AT THE SAME RATE.
WE NEED IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS TO
BALANCE THINGS OUT, WE CAN'T
FUND SOCIAL SECURITY, MEDICARE
AND STUFF WITHOUT IMMIGRANTS AND
IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN THAT WAY.
>> Ashley: JIMMY FAILLA, FOX
NEWS RADIO AND NATION,
INTERESTING TAKE SHE HAD, DID
SHE NOT CONSIDER WOMEN OR YOUNG
PEOPLE IN GENERAL JUST WANT TO
HAVE KIDS LATER IN LIFE AND PUSH
THEIR CAREERS FORWARD?
>> Jimmy: A LOT TO UNPACK HERE,
A LOT TO UNPACK.
>> Carley: SEVERAL SUITCASES.
>> Jimmy: AOC IS LOW IQ TIKTOKER
WHO SERVES IN CONGRESS.
THE CAVEAT, WE NEED LEGAL
IMMIGRATION, LEGAL IMMIGRATION
IS WHAT CONTRIBUTES TO SOCIAL
SECURITY AND FUNDS THE SYSTEM.
THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE OF TOWN IS
ANYTHING BUT LEGAL IMMIGRATION.
YOUNG PEOPLE AREN'T HAVING KIDS,
YOUR PARTY IS CHAMPIONING THE
IDEA OF NOT HAVING KIDS AS A
BADGE, ABORT THEM.
I'M SO PROUD IT IS ABORTION
TUESDAY.
>> Carley: I DIDN'T CONSIDER
THAT POINT.
>> Jimmy: THAT IS WHAT THEY DO.
>> Carley: BURDEN OF CAPITALISM
IS A THING, DID SHE GOOGLE THE
COLD WAR, THEY WERE LIVE ING
G
IN -- BURDEN OF CAPITALISM
LIVING IN THE MOST PROSPEROUS
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
>> Jimmy: I NEED TO LOSE WEIGHT,
I AM NOT SIGNING ON FOR
SOCIALISM, THIS IS LOW IQ TIKTOK
TIME.
>> Carley: AH.
SHALL WE TALK ABOUT THE HAPPIEST
PLACE ON EARTH?
DISNEY ONLY THE HAPPIEST PLACE
IF YOU ARE REALLY RICH, A
RESTAURANT CALLED VICTORIAN
ALBERT JUST INCREASED PRICES ON
PREFIX MENU, MOST EXPENSIVE
DINNER IS $200 MORE, COST $425
FOR THE PREFIX MENU OPTIONAL
WINE PAIRING STARTS AT $200, WHO
IS PAYING FOR THIS AT DISNEY?
>> Jimmy: THAT IS THE JOKE OF
DISNEY, THEY ARE YELLING ABOUT
INCLUSION AND PRONOUNS, IF YOU
WANT MORE PEOPLE TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE PARK, DON'T CHANGE THE
PRONOUN, CHANGE THE PRICE.
I AM STILL PAYING FROM 2012.
>> Carley: ZERO PROOF PAIRING, I
DIDN'T SAY THAT, I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT IT WAS, IT IS NONALCOHOLIC
ALCOHOL, THE STUFF I'M DRINKING
NOW AND CRYING INTO MY WINE
GLASS.
SARAH SAID AKA GRAPE JUICE.
THAT IS WHAT IT IS.
>> Jimmy: BY DISNEY STANDARDS
THIS IS ABSURD AND I'VE BEEN TO
EVERY FACET OF DISNEY, IT IS THE
MOST CLASSLESS PLACE IN THE
WORLD NOW.
>> Carley: IF YOU SAVE UP YOUR
MONEY, THIS RESTAURANT IS WORTH
IT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW, SEVEN COURSE
MEAL INCLUDES A BUSH OF CAVIAR
WITH KING GRAB, NEW ZEALAND
LANGOSHGSTINEWITH PASSION FRUIT
DIPPING SAUCE AND WILD BOAR AND
SALSA VERDE.
>> Jimmy: YOU CAN TURN TRICKS
BEHIND SPACE MOUNTAIN.
>> IS THIS A MITCH STAR
RESTAURANT?
>> Jimmy: I'M STICKING TO THE
PLACES MY MOM TOOK ME.
THAT IS WHAT I GREW UP GOING TO.
>> Carley: WE WERE TALKING ON
THE BREAK ABOUT WHAT WE WERE
CRAVING, DINER FOOD, DISCO
FRIES, CHICKEN FINGERS.
>> Jimmy: NICE GRA